expectations of a giant increase in
thanksgiving travel this year
and fears that there will be chaos at
airports aaa is predicting that more
than 53 million people will be driving
boarding a train or bus or yes flying
this holiday and air travel is expected
to be up 80 percent compared to last
year returning to near pre-pandemic
levels all that comes at a difficult
time for the industry airline industry
employees are not where they need to be
there are widespread staff shortages and
all federal employees which includes tsa
staff must be fully vaccinated by next
monday as of last month 40 percent of
tsa employees were not vaccinated or had
not submitted their vaccination status
so we are joined now by tsa
administrator david pakuski who oversees
security at nearly 440 airports in this
fine country he joins us now from
laguardia airport where i am certain he
did not have trouble with tsa
good morning mr administrator
let's start with the big picture people
are going to be flocking to airports in
the next couple of weeks what should
they expect
well they should expect that they will
we will meet our throughput standards i
mean if they're a standard lane
passenger it's going to take about 30
minutes if they're a pre-check passenger
10 minutes or less and i don't think
they should expect chaos we work very
closely with the airlines with the
airports we have travel projections for
the coming week and we're very confident
this is going to be a very smooth
operation uh over the next several days
i'm glad to hear you're confident the
reason people were wondering if maybe it
was going to be a problem is the the
mandate requiring vaccination among
federal employees and it seemed like a
big number of your employees were not
there yet has the number shifted what's
going on there
oh the number's improved greatly and i
don't expect the vaccine mandate to have
any impact whatsoever on thanksgiving
travel
and the good news for travelers is that
more and more people including tsa
employees are now vaccinated so from a
public health perspective it's a much
safer experience
will employees your tsa employees lose
their job if they're not vaccinated
well we will go through a progressive
discipline process with our employees
who have not been vaccinated but we have
a lot of employees who've asked for
either medical or religious exemptions
as well and so we'll go through the
process of looking at each one of those
individual cases and make a
determination over the next several
weeks so that yes there is the potential
if you
do not have an approved exemption and
you are not vaccinated that you will
lose your job because it's very
important that we have our workforce
fully vaccinated
you know another issue is
it's very disturbing issue scary i think
the outburst of passion of unruly
passengers it's actually gotten very
physical and very very dangerous how is
it affecting you and your team and what
are you guys doing about that
no you're right i mean you know the the
level of unruly passengers has gotten
very high uh and i've been the tsa
administrator for a little over four
years i have never seen it at these
levels what we're doing about it is
we're working very closely with the
carriers
the flight attendants the flight deck
crews the airports and the faa to do
everything that we can to message how
dangerous this behavior is what the
penalties are if you engage in it
and we're also working hard with with
flight attendants to provide
self-defense training and de-escalation
training for them and i would just say
at this point that you know really when
i look at this and i see these incidents
occurring
the flood attendants deserve enormous
credit uh for a very hard job to begin
with and then what they're dealing with
now uh in the year i mean it seems like
nearly every day there's a level of an
in-flight disturbance that gets beyond
the verbal argument and and gets into
some level of physical contact which is
something like i said that we hadn't
seen
in the past certainly not in my
experience as the administrator
david i want to stick with those unruly
passengers for a second whether it's
before uh during or even after the
flight you know as a parent the
knee-jerk reaction is to get involved
i'm traveling with my kids or my wife
and sometimes these workers seem a
little bit overwhelmed what would be
your advice to somebody that is sitting
back watching something going on and
thinking to themselves i should get
involved because the the people working
might need help
well i think the best advice i could
give is to try to de-escalate the
situation um and and that's part of the
trend that we provide uh and and if the
flight attendant asks for assistance uh
then to provide them the assistance that
they ask for i mean it it's hard
particularly hard if there's more than
one passenger involved in creating the
disturbance and oftentimes we see that
sometimes it's it's two passengers
seeing next to each other or a passenger
in front of another that you know
reclines the seat for example so things
that in the past were minor issues
seemed to be much more significant
issues to cause you know a physical
confrontation when it didn't happen that
way in the past generally
with these flights increasing and
holiday travel going up this information
is valuable david prakovsky thank you so
much we appreciate you joining us this
morning